[Music]
you're listening to
inside of you with michael rosenbaum
ryan got you sitting down again
oh you i think that's uh that's kind of
a thing
i'm gonna try and do it every time all
right i'm into it sure why not
yeah um before we get into it all right
we got a great episode and you know
especially when ryan goes i love this
episode
that was awesome yeah so we'll get into
ernie hudson in a minute but uh
it's it's uh it's been a crazy it just
gets crazier
now it's 2021 so it's sort of like all
right the end is near the
hopefully not the end but
who knows we're no we're good we're good
we're solid i want to say thank you to
everybody who uh
sends messages to hello
insideyoupodcast.com
uh the emails are just like hey mike you
don't have to respond
mike um you don't have to respond but uh
i love the podcast and you know i'm
gonna start reading letters again but
there's so many and it's just awesome
that people
get something out of it and uh if this
is your first time listening
i hope that uh you know you'll do us all
a favor and
write a review and uh subscribe write a
review on ample podcast it takes
literally
literally a second to do it you know um
and and they help they really help so if
you could do that that
you'd be surprised how far cause if
you're really enjoying the podcast and
you're writing me emails
write a review too um i do read all the
comments
and not that i respond to everyone
because that's an impossibility but uh i
read them and i cry
i weep and you know i apologize for last
week because i said that
my band sun spin the website would be
out well i had about 100 emails or 100
messages saying
we go to sunspin.com and there's nothing
that's because we had some
issues where we had to change some stuff
but um
we're hoping that you as you're
listening if you go to sunspin.com you
will see
the website uh i'm hoping it's out today
uh give it a shot let me know on the old
twitter
what are our handles on inside of your
podcast ryan oh at inside of you pod on
the tweets
uh inside of you podcast on instagram
facebook
youtube.com with michael rosamond
youtube.com inside of you on youtube
with michael rosenbaum that's the whole
thing youtube.com
inside of you with michael rosenbaum
okay you heard that three times
and i couldn't get it my retaining
ability has gotten lesser
it's uh i don't retain as well so is
your vocabulary
thank you was that was that vocabulary
not good
what did i say my retaining has gotten
lesser my retention
yeah that's what i meant did i not say i
knew what you meant yeah well it's good
that you know what i meant
it's good that my view listen i don't
i'm not an intellect
i don't sit here and say oh i'm mr
smarty pants i'm a guy who just talks to
people like a regular person like you
guys and that's what i do and hopefully
you enjoy it
why am i yelling i don't know i don't
know either but uh thank you for uh
our our support of the podcast my
patrons out there if you're
have enjoying patreon you gotta check it
out um
a lot of patrons and uh what a great
family it is and you get extra bonus
stuff and merch and
go to patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com
slash inside of you
and uh join the family i i send you a
message after you join i'll text you
uh but there's different tiers and it's
a blast and
i think people are really having a good
time and also our stage it where we play
music
sun spin we play covers and that's a
blast honestly i really love it it's the
last saturday of every month so it's
january 30th at 2 p.m and 6 p.m pacific
standard time
we're doing two shows we're working on
shows now if you have any idea for any
songs
let us know join us bring your friends
go to stageit.com
s-t-a-g-e it.com and just uh type in sun
spin and there's two shows and you go in
there you can follow me and i can tell
you when the shows are and
i always message people in there too so
thesunspin.com will have all the merch i
mean i'm staring at lunch boxes and
beanies
and and trucker hats and uh uh
coasters and ryan walked and goes god
what a merch wall
i'm like yeah man well it materialized
out of nowhere
it does all of a sudden yeah well you
know we're starting to get some merch
and also on the inside of you online
store
we've got i actually got some new stuff
coming but we got tumblers awesome
tumblers and mugs and
uh right now we got smallville lunch
boxes you can get signed
yeah i just figure you know people are
all over selling stuff autographed by me
or
by whatever and so i give some to
charity
so some will say this goes to charity
and
uh then you know it's for me and it's
not you're not
getting charged an arm and a leg what
these people are some people are
charging and good for them i hope
they're
making some money i'm not knocking them
but i'm like yeah
well at least you know it's coming
straight from the horse's mouth
meow so that's it on that end uh anyway
look let's get into it um
this guy's been around forever and it's
one of those guests that i didn't know i
haven't talked to
and you know i always get a little like
worked up and but you know him from
ghostbusters and
i mean he's been in everything he's done
tons of television but he gets
really really personal and
we talk about so many great things and i
can't wait what was your favorite thing
that without giving it away that we got
into
today oh god just uh his kids
like how he disciplined his kids and
like how we kind of got into the acting
business was really cool
broke down and out went and saw a play
when huh yeah i mean
and uh you know you found out that the
one thing you wanted to do was be a dad
and i thought that was really neat
yeah man because you know he didn't know
his dad his dad left when he was young
when he
before he was born and his mom died when
he was young like
like three months old and so
you think i don't want freaking kids but
it's a great story and
without further ado let's get inside of
the legendary
ernie hudson it's
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
damn it i knew you'd look good i knew it
just it just
you look better at 60 what are you 65
no 75 man what how do you look so good
man what are you are you doing are you
juiced up what at the hell
well thank you i'll just say thank you
man it's a new year and uh
no i just you know things are good you
know um
but uh but thank you for the compliment
that's a good way to start the euro
well hey you're welcome and it's a
pleasure having you here and uh
you know i was talking to you know every
every white guy always says he has black
friends
but i have i've always had a lot of
black friends i've had black roommates
and like that you know and so of course
i call all my black friends to say
ernie hudson's coming on the show
they're like what that's the exact
response what
and then they start talking and they go
over and they know you like inside out
and they were really pumped
which made me nervous because i know
they're gonna finally listen to my show
great you know what i mean so i know
you've been doing a lot of press
and stuff like that for um redemption
day and i didn't get a chance to watch
the movie but
the the trailer was intense as [ __ ]
usually
you watch these trailers and the
publicists send this stuff and you're
like oh okay okay
and this was intense and i was like i
wanted to see more you because you
it seemed like you were kind of the the
leading man's mental like
you had to keep him in the right state
of mind but also you were boxing and
fighting i saw i was like okay i got to
see more of ernie here
so yeah you know it's funny because as
we get older
uh i'm always like well how come i'm not
in the fight scene and how come i don't
kick the door in
and because they they see a number and
they kind of go
but this is a movie you know about this
um uh vet
um you know there's a crisis situation
he's going to rescue his wife
and i play his dad i'm now the dad i
play the dad
i'm everybody's dad um even though
it's hard because we never see ourselves
that way but right um
but he's um you know my character is is
kind of
uh you know he's a dad whose son is sort
of unraveling and
having a lot of issues with the ptsd and
um and you know he's in a very delicate
place because a lot of guys end up
committing suicide and on and on and on
um and when the son has his crises
um so i'm kind of there to support i'm a
guy who
trained him to fight when he was a kid
i'm the guy who
he followed into the military and so
just my responsibilities as a dad that's
kind of what i
i do in the movie but gary dearden um
who stars in the movie
he's great he uh played my nephew on i
have a television show i
i exactly produce called the family
business on bt
and gary played my nephew for a while
until we killed him all
nice but uh so i felt i i wanted to be
in this movie um and be there to support
him as well so
that's awesome now you have four kids
right how many are boys
yeah i have four sons four sons
[Music]
um all just very different
and uh and uh but all great guys and
then i have
two grandsons three granddaughters
um two great-grandsons and one
great-granddaughter
so life happens you know and
um it does i'm not a dad i'm 48 my
grandmother's 92 and she's like you'd be
such a great dad i'm like yeah you say
that
and then you have the kid and then
you're like and then i know how much i
get mad at myself
and i'm like god i'm a terrible father
and i'm this and then i can't my
depression i can't sink any lower i
can't do it ernie i can't do that to
myself
i think don't you have to be mentally
prepared to have children well i think
you um
uh you know it's the only thing that i
ever wanted to do
i like you know people say well you want
to be an actor um
but as a kid the only thing i wanted you
was to be a dad because i didn't have a
dad
i don't know what relationship you have
with your father but i didn't have a dad
uh i didn't know my mom so for me to get
the chance to be a dad
was like the ultimate most important
thing ever
see that's right i had to do it it's not
that you're better prepared
but i will say parenthood is not for
everybody
and um and that's that's definitely well
you know i look at that i look at your
story and i don't think a lot of people
know that
but you know you didn't know your father
and your mom passed away when you were
just a couple months old and i'm like
i had parents i was from a dysfunctional
family i mean we are dysfunctional i
mean if the more you sit here with me
you will realize that ernie's those
families are
i know everybody nobody gets a clear
break
every family in one way or the other
some more some of them more than others
i will admit but
um yeah they're all dysfunctional but
but you said at a young age you were you
were like i want to be a dad was it
because you know he was like i didn't
have a dad
my mom i didn't know my mom i want to
have a family and create
this atmosphere that i didn't have as a
kid and this is what i want to create
some kind of like
something you didn't have is that it
yeah i think as a kid
and because you know i didn't nobody
knew who my father was
and so i would really young i would kind
of
latch on to men and kind of hang around
and hope they would kind of
you know like me and want to be my dad
and then they would all say get help
with me and that was always so
so i thought when i grow up i'm going to
be a good dad and i'm going to do
all the things that nobody did with me
and
um and so yeah it was my way i thought
of
yeah doing and giving being there for
somebody the way
nobody was ever there for me but i
realized later on
that uh your issues are your issues not
theirs
uh but still i will say being a parent
was the best thing ever happened to me i
think kids
will make you more than uh than what you
are you dig
so deep you know you go to places for
your kids that you wouldn't even
consider for yourself you know
the things you could do that you kind of
go now i mean i can sleep
outside but my kid no i'm sorry but
you're
you're level-headed though like i i can
just tell by talking to you for like a
few minutes that
you know some of the roles you play are
not so level-headed
and then some of the rules you put so
it's all over i mean you're an actor
you're a great actor
so but then when you're a parent
how do you i mean you got to be the bad
cop sometimes you got to be the
i mean like my dad i'd rather him smack
me in the back than yell at me his voice
was so
powerful like don't ever let me tell you
that again
and i was like oh my god it was just
terrifying like did you have to hold
yourself back because
kids could piss you off and the worst
kids are kids that aren't yours
when you have kids over your house with
your friends kids
and they break [ __ ] you can't reprimand
the child you have to say uh
john uh could you talk to your child
that just broke my uh my uh
my star wars toy that i shouldn't have a
48 year old man
but what like what do you like you know
people say well you really love children
i go i love my kids
but uh you know but it's
yeah there's a way that uh my son uh
recently told me about an incident and
he's um he's 50 now 50
rocky's 52. and he told me about an
incident that happened
and uh and i and it was just awful and
he's been he was really kind of upset
about it i said well man so what did i
do
i mean because i know i didn't hit you
and he said no no
he said but it's the way you looked at
me and i'm like
that's good that's a lot i knew i had a
way of looking at my kids
like okay that's it you know cut it
and and i could always you know i always
had that
i didn't do it often but when i you know
because if we go beyond this point
you're in trouble you're in seriously
wait a minute you you didn't give them
the death look very often
yeah well you know if we're in public
and you you start to get a little crazy
on me
dude you don't want me to go there you
know and i would always
suppose and you know i won't say i never
whipped my kids
because in those days you did but i
would always negotiate it's like okay
listen
what you're doing is really kind of
stupid and crazy and i understand
you did it but maybe it was a mistake so
i'm gonna assume it was a mistake but
i don't have this conversation again and
then a second time all right you did it
again
now if you do it i think you want me to
do something crazy too
so i'm telling you
do this again and we're going to be so
after about three warnings and it's like
okay all right this is this is
apparently what you want to happen
but uh but we never really got to that
right
final well i got it really i should say
rarely i once said
all kids are different four sounds and
they're totally
what worship one does not work for the
other so that was the other
hard reality also the hard reality is i
wanted to be a dad because i thought i
wanted to do it right
and no matter how right you think you
got it they say you know you really
you screwed me up there and you really
kind of you know you were awful to me
and you weren't there for me and i mean
what you know we remember different
things right my son
once i was a single dad i was a single
dad and he was at uh columbia in new
york
and that was costing a lot of money and
i went to see him and he said dad
you know he says um you know you've just
never been there for me i'm like
i i've been this single dad since she
was seven years old
if i said if you think about when you
learn to ride a bicycle i'm the guy that
was running behind the bike holding
you up i mean every single birthday i'm
the guy who bought that
but kids will interpret it's not what
happens is how they interpret things and
you have to be
able to say okay i mean it hurt me at
the time i mean i
remember i was standing there crying
because i thought how do you say
i'm not um i mean decline
sorry sorry about that that happens to
me too i have to decline yeah
i still don't yeah but yeah no so
parenting is not uh no matter how
well you think you do it they're gonna
find issues yeah
that's difficult and you know my my
friend chris and roger and i
we we always talk and we're like you
know sometimes when we got hit we're
like
we deserved it man we i mean kids
nowadays get away with murder they're on
their things and they're not listening
and they're just like
and like they're like no don't hit the
child it's not that you hit the child
but like a little smack in the ass
it's like i'm on man like hey snap out
of that what are you doing
i got what's called mall arm i just made
that up but it's called mall arm
um where i'm in the mall and i'm just
being goofy and yelling and doing stuff
and my dad goes stop
that and then i'm like yeah i'm gonna
stop that
and then i do it and then he just grabs
your arm and you're just like it's like
oh it's the scariest thing in the world
do you ever give them a little mall arm
to the child
oh yeah you know i know they'll be the
we're definitely not going here in
public you're not you're not going to do
this to me
out here so uh yeah you but i always
would
we we always especially my older two
boys i have four sons so
the younger two um you know
me and their mom we've been together
throughout their whole lives so it's a
whole other experience i mean you know
they
they would always go to mom you know
anything that happened mom
you know dad is looking crazy but uh
but the older two boys you know it was
give me that look again
yeah yeah it's uh they could always run
to mom
but um yeah you know there's certain
things i mean
i always tell my kids you can talk to me
when it was small
you can talk to me about anything i
don't care what it is how
oft i don't care there's nothing you
can't talk to me about
but how you talk to me you can't talk to
me anyway
you got to i and and i don't ask for
anything i won't give i'm never going to
disrespect you
i promise you but on the same token you
gotta
you know i i'm not asking anything that
i'm going so that was always my
um and we would talk we talked about
stuff that other parents probably
wouldn't but if they want to talk about
it
like sex talk sex talk they'd have sex
talk
whatever ooh i could never do that with
my dad oh me and my grandmother who
raised me you're kidding i can't even
say the word
sex i mean it was but um but no i just
feel that um
most things i remember when they were
real young my two older boys like about
uh maybe three and six and uh
and and we would have our talks and i
said listen you know you guys
um because i felt they were holding
something back something had happened
so i said you know it's okay if you guys
want a curse i said you know now
normally you can't curse in front of me
but just while we're talking now use any
language you want to
use it so it's okay it's like it's it's
just for now
you know and suddenly the words started
rolling out of their mouths i'm like
literally i was like you didn't know
they knew those words
yeah i i i yeah stuff that i didn't
hadn't said and they
of course kids know you know but uh they
they keep it from you
but um and i kind of go okay it's uh now
time's up
i don't hear anymore and they've always
been this thumbs up
in fact i never want to play this game
again that's it you said enough for 50
of those games
yeah my dad was always like the extreme
like i think he did a lot of drugs when
he was young
and uh you know so it was like i never
smoked i never drank
i never did this if i ever find this
you're going to a halfway house i
remember
the neighbor gave me a pierced my ear
and i came home looking at my dad with
just my left side of my face
and i said hey dad would you care if i
got your ear pierced you'd you'd go out
you'd be out of the house if you got
your ear
pierced you get your ear pierced you're
out of the house i'm like all right i'm
gonna stay at nate's for the next four
days so this heels
you know what i mean he was like
extremely strict then i found cigarettes
then i was at his dentist in long island
years later
i had graduated high school and i was at
long island the guy was doctor
fight tooth decay with dr j and he lived
on long island and he did
the work out of his house how i didn't
get an infected mouth i don't know
but i remember talking to this man and i
was like yeah was my dad always been
such a you know a kind of a you know
conservative tight ass he's your father
used to
whip it out he used to swear he used to
he did they think he invented cocaine he
he starts going on about my dad i'm like
what are you talking this is not the
so you find out things about were you
one of those fathers that just like you
wanted them to think you were perfect or
did you say hey i did this i did this or
maybe
you didn't yeah no i i i feel that the
best thing i can do for you
is to be honest that's why i never if
you if you want to bring the subject up
i'm going to tell you the truth
so if you don't want the truth don't
bring it up
i always wanted them to see exactly who
i am because uh
you know i don't i'm not hiding anything
but my kids probably know me better than
anybody else i mean i
um and i and i can relate to
you know they go through that i realize
it's i tell my kids
um i know what it's like to be
21 but i don't know what it's like to be
now you know what i mean it's a you
you're seeing things that i didn't see
so i'm not going to judge you
because i come from a different time and
a different experience and i can i can
appreciate that
right um i have an opinion but your
opinion is probably more valuable
than mine as far as you're concerned
because you know what i didn't know
and i think i've always felt that way
with them um
but i never wanted to i don't yeah i
know i don't like to
and even in general i don't like
covering up hiding stuff
i got nothing to hide i'd rather have it
all out there
and then live with the consequences then
to always be afraid that the
consequences will pop up at the worst
time
ernie i know this is going to sound
weird but would you be my father
i mean i mean that's that's pretty
amazing how you can be so
just like hey if you want to know the
truth this is what i did there's there's
really
i think that actually helps the child
you know if i said dad
might if my dad took me aside and said
listen i drank i did this
and it messed me up and i had a really
tough time
and if you're gonna ever try that and i
hope you're smart enough not to but if
you get into trouble
you'd call me and and i'd be that was
not the
that he was not that guy he was you're
going away if
you get caught if i catch you drink so
there was almost that like i wanted to
fight back
like screw you man i'm gonna do what i
want so kids it's a hard balance i i
wouldn't know how to be a father and i i
like i give him the benefit of the doubt
he did the best i always say
he did the best he could that's what he
did yeah that's what he did i bet you
know
you know how to do and um and you have
to respect that you know yeah because
you can never know what they're saying
most of it's fear
i think if i was really afraid that
maybe they would judge me they wouldn't
respect me
if they knew that i did something but i
always felt like hey man this is
this is it and um and i have value
no matter what i did so i didn't feel i
had but a lot of parents are a little
bit afraid of
if they really knew the truth about me
or something right you know
when i was i was broke and i was losing
my house and
i was in you know just really
uh i wasn't going to pretend that
everything was fine man i'm you know i'm
out here we're broke i got no money
and i don't know what i'm going to do so
someday if you ever get to this place
um you know just know that this can
happen if you
make certain choices wow well you know
this
this helps a lot thank you for the
therapy but like into your career now
like you know you're spacing all this
adversity you don't know your parents
you're growing up with your
with your uh your grandmother arana is
that right yeah arena yeah
anna and you know she's obviously
teaching you some good values because
look at the man you become i mean was
she like very was she strict was she a
disciplinarian
no you know um i remember the last
whipping i got
i was about 11 years old because that
was you know kind of her way and she she
was really hard with her kids
so when i came along she was just kind
of and we went to church a lot
and she would always um because i was
always curious about what they were
talking about she would always kind of
break it down in a way that
that i could understand so we had long
long conversations
but but when i would do something rarely
when i do something she would find the
ultimate thing was whipping when i got
to be 11
i didn't wash your dishes and she gave
me a time limit to wash them
she went to church came back the
audition still won watches she just had
an officer she got the belt out
and she said i want a whoopi and she
started whipping me what
in my mind i thought because i would
always be so afraid it's like it would
just freak me out be screaming because i
didn't want to get a whip and i'd be
crying
then i thought well i wonder how bad it
would be
so i just kind of um i was sort of
standing there and she hit me and i
thought
well it's it's not bad you know and she
hit me and she
kept i thought you know it's it's yeah
it's okay i mean that's not as bad as i
thought i'm kind of processing when this
is and she just exhausted herself
and uh and i'm like come sit down you
need some water here
so oh my gosh the last whipping i ever
got
later on i wish i still got whippings
because she didn't with me but she would
lay that guilt on me which is worse than
whipping
but um but i think yeah she has realized
that
she couldn't take that approach because
honestly it
it didn't as long as you're afraid of it
but once you kind of face that i'm like
you know what i i'm not afraid of that
um
with a friendship we had a partnership
with a friendship i think
um that um that was how we
we worked our our stuff out
inside of you is brought to you by
wondering wondry's new
true crime podcast the apology line
begins with alan bridges posting flyers
around new york city
asking people to anonymously apologize
for their crimes not to god not to the
police
but to his answering machine within
hours the calls start
coming in people apologizing for
stealing
infidelity lying and even murder
allen got dozens of calls from people
claiming to be murderers but one
stood out richie
he was deliberate measured and his calls
would leave thousands
wondering if he really was the serial
killer he claimed to be
that is until richie offered to provide
proof
of his crimes unable to just listen
anymore
allen knew he had to try and stop him
if you're listening to the audio version
of our show stick around to the
end to hear a preview of the apology
line or you can listen right now
on apple podcasts inside of you is
brought to you by
geico michael do you own or rent your
home i do ryan i
i own my home and i bet that could be
some hard work it is
you gotta you gotta make you don't wanna
dip into savings or anything you gotta
pay your mortgage it's not easy yes
exactly and i know a lot of people
probably struggle a lot of people
struggle paying their rent or mortgage
it's the hardest thing to do
you know what's easy what bundling
policies with geico bundling policies so
what does that mean ryan does that mean
that you don't have to pay for
do three different insurances are you
talking what are you talking about i'm
talking about bundling it all together
so you
you bundle your homeowners and renters
insurance along with your auto policy
i mean so i could pay them all with
geico all with geico all in one place
all bundled together well i don't know
about you guys but that sounds pretty
damn easy and cool to me
it's a good thing too because you
already have so much to do around your
home
right that's true i'm always working on
my home i'm always doing stuff and
you know the last thing i want to do is
pay three different people for my house
and my auto and whatever else you know
what i'm saying go to geico.com get a
quote and see how much
you could save it's geico easy folks
visit
geico.com today that's geico.com
even a rosenbomb can do it
so you grew up in michigan i grew up in
indiana small town
um okay and and i really didn't get it
together i'm still trying to get it
together
in terms of like figuring out who i am
and all these things i think you found
out at a young age which
then you became this playwright and you
were doing all these things and i just
was
you know how were you did you excel in
school i mean to be a player right
you've got to be a good writer you've
got to know all the
i mean you did you do well uh no i think
i graduated high school with a
1.7 average i mean you know it's like um
that's for me well you know my
grandmother who was born in 1895 for her
of the biggest thing is if you finish
high school that was the only thing she
ever asked me just finished high school
because she thought
you know you finish high school you're
good to go but in 1964
that was not the case and so i didn't
really i just wanted to finish high
school which
i just didn't really uh work very hard
until the last year in high school when
i began to realize that
oh my god this is my life and so i
decided to join the uh the marine corps
because
that was kind of my safety and then i
got discharged from marines because i
had asthma
and i found myself back at home a little
bit lost and then
then i got married and then we had a kid
and then i went
what the hell this is my life and it's
over
so that's when i began to think outside
the box and say okay
i always liked writing poems and little
plays and stories
and so when i finally managed i went to
detroit and got into college
um that was kind of a natural and you
know
extension but when i first got
discovered theater and walked on stage i
knew
that this is because up until then i've
been trying to get a good job i've been
trying to you know
take care of my family i've been working
hard doing
and i was i just felt so bad at
everything
that when i got to theater it was like
wow i i i got this i can do this
and something made sense to me how old
were you
probably about 22. so it was an audition
or a play
no maybe 21 somewhere near 21-22 and was
it a play or an audition for something
or what was it yeah it was a play i mean
i i took this uh
well first my wife and i we went to
detroit and like i said we were married
had a kid
um and just uh
you know i'm just trying to find a way
to not have to work in a
factory my whole life so um
uh we had an argument uh of one of those
you know you just she just really got on
mine
i just had to get the hell out right so
i got in my car and i'm driving around
detroit i got nowhere to go and i don't
want to go back home
and so i drive by this little building
it has a marquee out front and there
there's a lineup of people
and i was like wow was kind of curious
about it so i parked the car and i asked
what was going on and the guy said
it was a play it was a detroit repertory
theater
and so i thought i'm not going back home
so i got in line
and i went in and sat down and
this play the curtains came up and and
there was a play about a father whose
daughter had disobeyed him and got in
trouble
and so he disowned her and then finally
in the end they reconciled
it was amazing it was i was so blown
away it was just
i sat there after everybody left
thinking wow i mean that is so
those actors if i could do that i mean
but it was just i could never do that
and then that fall um i needed an
elective
and um so i took an acting class and
when i when i when i said i walked to
the scene
in the class which was held in this
theater
um called the hillberry theater when i
walked
on stage i just felt at home
i just felt at home i thought this is
and then when i began to understand what
was required what the acting was what
i'm like okay
if i can i i got this this first time i
felt
really good at something wow you weren't
nervous
people said well you you do what you
love to do and i kind of go you know
it's
essential because i don't i do love it
but i do
what i can do i just could never do
anything else you know i mean i
i could kind of do it but i wasn't the
best at it
whereas with the acting i felt like i
can at least aspire
to be the best at and you weren't
nervous
did you get the fear at first or are you
just like i there was this innate
confidence to you
well it was um you know i was always
learning and picking up it wasn't the
fear as much as i i need to know that i
gotta prepare i gotta make sure i gotta
put whatever but
no i mean i i can do this i mean my fear
is i can't get a job and i can't pay the
rent and i
don't have a real lifestyle but this is
i learn the lines i see the lines and
then i get paid i mean
okay all right but here's what i'm
thinking you just got in a huge fight
with your wife it's bad you have to get
out of there you go see a play in
detroit
you fall in love with the theater and
then you go back home that night and you
say you know what honey
who's pissed off at me just speak
speaking of not making any money
i want to be an actor i mean what well
you know when i went back home because i
didn't you know we talked about the plan
i'm sure
but i at that point i didn't even
imagine i just i didn't even think it
would be possible for somebody like me
to be an actor that was like
i saw these actors they were bigger than
life i'm like man this is
it was it was too big a prayer to have
to to pray
right right but that ball when i took
the acting class and i began to
get a sense of this is how it's done and
i heard all the horror stories
the following year i left and went out
to la
trying to find work and get in not to be
an actor just trying to find
work and i was i couldn't get connected
and i called home and my wife and i'll
always give her credit for this
she said well why don't you there's
nothing going on once you come back
and um and and get into acting and do
that acting thing you really like that
and i said well i can't be an actor
because actors you know they they
the average income for an actor is less
than the janitors make i mean actors
you can't make a living at it and she
said you know you're broke already
you're not going to lose any money so
at least you'll be doing something like
wow and
uh and i came back and i got in theater
and
i got cast in a play called the emperor
jones and
from then on it was my life and um and
i've always managed to make a living
at acting and this was in 1960
1960 no i guess yeah it was just a 1960
wow you know you asked me how old i was
so this was in 1966 something like that
but i always managed to and now not
always a great lifting i mean i
you do a play and they pay you a couple
thousand bucks and you use that to pay
the rent right
gas in the car and you do you it was a
hustle
you know some local tv stuff i was able
to do but i always managed to hustle
enough
to where i could be full-time at i would
i had dinner with uh joy montagna
and uh joey panleoni and i know
him yeah yeah tim daly we're all having
dinner
and they were talking about different
jobs they had along the way
and i said you know i never really had
once i've committed to acting
um that's what i've been able to do um
you know i never had to go and be a
waiter or whatever
this is that's amazing did anybody who
was the first person you recall
that because i think this means a lot
you have people along the way mentors
certain people who just believe in you
and everybody says no
no no and there's one that goes you're
really who do you remember
said hey you've got something
this is there's something here you're
you got this you should really do this
yeah well you know obviously nobody that
you
know family or friends that's all right
that's like
you know you're out of your mind first
off i was married
you know first thing you could be an
actor in detroit i mean really
um you know you're going to quit your
factory job and do this thing
but um that professor i had a guy named
earl d.a smith who was just amazing
and a guy named david rigo the ones who
produced the uh
the emperor jones um they were really
you know they were really and also i
would always get cast in the lead
um even when i started out um
so and we did and the reviews were
always really good
saying that i was whatever so it was all
these
in signs along the way you know always
saying theater is like a love affair
it's got to be two ways but when you're
putting everything out and she's not
giving
anything back maybe it's time to
maybe it's over right right so she's
always giving me enough back to let me
know that she's
that yeah she loves me so and
that's how i love my son's a musician
he's struggled and he's in his 50s now
and i'm saying well you know but
um i don't know i mean from my
perspective
she hasn't really you know you've given
a whole lot more than she's given
you but because you as a dad you can't
say that but a certain way you you know
you want to be supportive but
it's it's interesting i'm going through
a thing like that you know
me i've always loved music i've loved it
more than anything in my life even
though i've acted my whole life
and had a lot of success with acting um
and then i always said you know i
shouldn't do this because i'm not as
good of a singer or as good of a
musician but
i was like well that's absolutely
asinine now there's a difference between
if you're trying to do something to
become to make a lot of money from it to
be
whatever it is you want to become a rock
star or whatever and so right
for your son the same thing so i i think
i love it so much that it would be a
disservice to myself and my mental
well-being
not to do it yeah so there's no reason
why you shouldn't continue to be
passionate and love what you do
and if something happens great but have
no expectations other than just trying
to be great
that's what mate has helped me out with
my because i'm always trying i got to be
great at this i got to be great at this
if i'm not great then i'm a failure and
that's something that's i've been
working on
in therapy and all that [ __ ] so i i feel
like
it's great that he's still playing it's
great that he's doing his thing yeah and
yeah you know if he loves it keep doing
it but if that's what he's trying to
make a living off of you know it could
be
putting pressure on yourself right yeah
i feel the same way i think you we're
called to certain things
but sometimes when you do a certain
thing another path will light up
you know what i mean and you start out
this way most of the directors and
producers i know
started out trying to be an actor or
trying to be something else and then
they
sort of it's connected uh whatever
but i think you you have to do what you
do but you still have to
especially when in my son's case you've
got
uh kids you know what i mean and so
you you have a responsibility i i would
never
um say sacrifice my kids because i want
to do the acting
you know i mean it's uh i gotta find a
way to
they they have to come first at least
until they're able to to do
so um but you have children and so you
can still do music but maybe
you have to work a job and do it at
night all right until you can get that
deal
now if i had to work a job as soon as
an acting job came up i never worked a
job that i
couldn't quit you know what i mean i'm a
job that was so important to me it's
like as soon as anything happens i'm out
of here right
but but i gotta find a way to pay the
rent
and so if it means that i
you know i said i can sleep on the
street but my kids can't sleep on the
street
right so if if my business my career
my acting doesn't love me enough
then i gotta i gotta i gotta get some
someone who does and then we'll just
have a little side affair here you know
exactly you know and that's how i until
i can find a way that uh
that's helpful yeah but i think children
are
that's a big part when you got kids um
or you have other responsibilities but
you know i'm responsible for myself
and as a dad i kind of go you know it's
not my responsibility i mean i'll take
on a lot i'll be there for you
about thing is you know the difference
between you and me
is you have me i didn't have a meet i
didn't have somebody who i could you
know
and i want to be there to support you if
you come to me and you're trying to do
something and you have
85 and you need that extra 15
to kind of get over when you come to me
and you said it's something you want to
do and you only have five percent and
you want me to kick in the other 95
something's wrong and i like it
you know that happens more often than
not i'm like dude this is this is your
thing that i'm
you know i i love you but uh you know
i'm not
so that is a dad yeah yeah it's a little
hard you know and
you know how much it means to him but
you don't want to be disappointed you
don't want to disappoint someone but
right you love music as a part of you
yeah i i would
i wish i i um could play music you know
i i consider my body
as my instrument but i would love to be
able to play i could definitely make
sense out of
guitar there's nothing by the way guitar
is easy to learn
i'm telling you there's the tutorials
i've been playing a while but
to learn a g a d and a c you could
pretty much play every hit you've ever
heard
i mean and it's easy and once you get
some calluses on your fingers
you got nothing to do you just grab a
guitar off the shelf and just kind of
strum
and it's just soothing yeah you should
i'd love to do that and maybe now at
this point because now i have a little
more time because
not chasing that that acting thing uh it
might be fun to
i've always liked to sing so be able to
play with that
um that would be it would be kind of fun
so you're a good
singer well i don't know about a good
singer i say i like just what are you
saying
yeah i just i i've been paid to sing i
used to do musicals years ago
uh i can learn a song i'm not a singer
uh but yeah you know i mean i can
i can hold a uh you know i can hold the
tune i can um
yeah let's do bee gees right now let's
do the beaches let's do the beach
it was a song i learned in grade school
uh start the day with the song how'd it
go i
i just say i i feel better when i sing i
sing
you know it's uh yeah that's true
i'm telling you right before we did this
ryan and i were singing
on the nights on broadway doing the bee
gees
saying that and we were just having fun
and it's just like you automatically
there's a life and a spirit in a
it's just it's it's i love it i love
music um
i wanted to ask you about you know you
got you started
acting at it you know things started
happening and you started
i mean you did the the i guess the
sequel to um dolomite
and you did uh you did a bunch of roles
now i did like i i think about these
things
because a lot of people don't realize
how typecast what is typecasting
especially if you're not in the business
do you think it had to just irk the hell
out of you because
again i talked to my african-american
friends they're like
dude we're playing the pimp or we're
playing this and they're not giving us
opportunities and they're not
and you see it and you're like you're
right like how did this go on for so
effing long and were you one did it just
piss you off because here you are a town
actor you're working
and obviously you became a legend but in
the beginning you're doing all this
stuff
did that bother you a lot that all these
roles like black guys were getting
women black women they were they were
getting the same roles
yeah yeah i mean it's um certainly the
projects weren't i love now that it's
more diverse and and hollywood has
stepped up and tried to be more
inclusive and so you see shows that uh
you never would have seen even 10 years
ago
but uh but in those i think it
frustrated a lot of people because um
yeah it was you know with some negative
role and definitely it's not about you
but i um my thing was always a little
bit different i guess i never
if i was playing up him i never really
saw him as a pimp i was playing this guy
who just happened to be a pimp i know
it's kind of a weird thing i was like oh
i'm the stereotypical i'm like this is a
guy who's in trouble and he's doing some
things and
um and so my i went from sort of being
that heavy because i was kind of
physically fit
so i'd be that heavy you know the kind
of
guy and um but it was always it was
always personal you know it was always i
was playing this guy
and um then i went to best friends
suddenly i was doing a lot of movies
where i was best friends
you know i'm in the story uh
but it's about robbie benson but i'm
robbie's best friend
right and um so it was always very hard
to find those things that
um that i'm a central part of the
storytelling and that's
very frustrating because um
[Music]
or you're in the thing one of the things
that happened when i
did the first ghostbusters it came out
it was such a big hit
and um i used to get invited to come to
schools and talk to the kids
and uh and i would go there and i'd make
a monterey ghostbusters you know
um nice and the teachers liked it
because the kids would play ghostbusters
but they wouldn't fight each other they
would chase the imaginary ghosts and
trap him and all that
so uh but one of the things that kids
would answer
at first it confused me because the kids
would they would say
where does winston go and i'm like where
does winston go and he said yeah
where does winston go because he was in
he was there with
with the other ghostbusters and then he
left where did he go home
where is his home you know does he is he
married does he have kids
we don't know a damn thing about winston
where's bill murray we kind of see him
in his you know his little
studio or danny in his little lab or or
you know we we get a sense of you know
what is outside of what we're seeing but
with winston he's just
there he just pumps up and um
so that's um that's it's
frustrating that's changed a lot um but
in the meantime you know you have to
keep
you know keep working hopefully you can
bring something but i will say
and a lot of people would not like to
hear me say this
a lot of times i had a friend uh were
auditioning for this thing and he came
in
looking so ridiculous and he was doing
this really stereotypical
interpretation and i said man what are
you doing
and he said yeah yeah you know and i
said well why are you doing that way me
why are you kind of shocking and doing
whatever the hell you're doing
and he said you know that's what they
want and so that's what who wants to say
that's what they want
and that that's it they want us to be
that way and so
the assumption is that i better go ahead
and do that and i just
i never assumed playing winston that i
had to be subservient
that's sad that it makes me feel makes
me feel kind of bad that he would
think that but he was probably had
rightfully so the role
unless i've been on uh auditions where
people in fact
uh one of my actor friends i came in and
it was part of it was a part of a cook
really
but i came in i had a t-shirt on my arms
he said man you better go you've got to
comfortably cut your arms up
and i said why is it anyone that you
want to scream with your arms like that
man you know that
brother come in because you're gonna be
and i'm like uh
who says this but it's all these
assumptions and actually
you helped perpetuate this stereotype
unknowingly because you are doing what
you think
they want you to do and until somebody
comes along and kind of go
why can't i produce it why can't i
direct it or why wow
that um it changes that's more powerful
that's pretty powerful grew up believing
what we should say they'll never see an
interracial relationship on tv they'll
never see
you'll never see that because
and for a long time you do i mean for a
long time it's like oh well
it's not going to happen um and now i'm
lilly tomlin's boyfriend
that's amazing but you had a different
perspective ernie
you that that's a rare that you had a
certain innate like
ability to come up with these roles or
have a personality and you didn't like
say oh this is the pimp roll or this is
the the cop and i'll be like this and
i'll be
like some you had a perspective on this
character which
i i obviously gave you a lot i knew guys
who considered themselves
pimps but i didn't see them as pimps i
knew him as my friend um
you know um german you know
jeremy's a pimp but jeremy i know jeremy
i know his mother i know he's jeremy
you know he he's a person he's not a
pimp
and a lot of actors felt like you want
me to play the pimp no
i want you to play jeremy winston is
winston i don't want winston to be the
black guy
right and i've done shows where even the
directors would kind of
not so suddenly say uh ernie um could
you you know just
do it a little more you know that that
thing you do and i said what thing
well yeah you know you know the
giant i mean just just make him a little
more
come on man do that thing you do and i'm
like i don't do that thing i don't know
what the hell
oh my god dude i could just see him all
right
this guy is he's a guy who's trying to
feed his family and he may have to do
these things but he's not
you know we we see we think we know
everything about him but you
that's not who this man is and so if i
play him
to be this thing then then he's not a
person so i had to
even though i did one show it's called
too close for comfort oh i used to love
that show
yeah so i played the part where
um they accidentally knocked a hole in
the wall
and so to get it repaired uh there's a
prison system where they
the former prisoners uh you can hire
them
to help you know so they they call the
hotline
and they hire me and my uh ex
felony partner is a white guy and so
we uh walk in the house and they show us
the hole in the in the wall
and so my line is holding my helia
no i don't even know what the hell it
means i'll be honest with you i'm like
i don't understand and uh he said no no
just just say it
and so i would say uh holy man don't
know sid with energy and he wants me to
do this holy my hell yeah
and i like this is crazy so i talked to
ted knight and
i said tim do you understand this and
ted is like no what the hell does that
mean doesn't make any sense to me and
all the other actors are like
no you don't just say that don't see it
and then finally the producer said
listen when you auditioned you said it
and you said it perfectly
and i hired you for that night you
saying holy hell yeah or i'll get
somebody
else who will now i need the job
so i walked in and i said holy my hell
yeah [ __ ] it i mean
but it seems like what does that
even mean i never heard anybody say that
expression
so it's always a little bit of that and
sometimes you have to go you know what
i'm not doing that
um i did a show in the very beginning
years ago called high cliff manor
with shelly fabre and steve mccaddy and
um
and it was about it was a pilot it was a
series
um and uh i played uh
a voodoo priest um who had crossed the
uh the atlantic in a canoe um
me and steve mccaddy and uh so every
other line was moana
and uh and i had gold teeth and
uh earring and um
no no sabuana it was just weird and i
really i mean i was me and the kids you
know things were really tight and i
wanted the job it was paying more money
i haven't made and i'm like
i went in and uh and i got the part
and i worked on it for about three days
and then
i just i just had a hard time you know
just so the goal all that stuff
and so finally i went to uh the
producers and um
i said you know i i i can't do this
i mean first his name was uh bamboo
and uh and i said you know i they're
guys who would jump up and down to get
this role but
i i i can't so i just quit and wow
and uh they called me that night and
said hey we don't understand i said well
listen i
you know i got kids man and i just you
know i
i can try to work around something but
this is just no i can't do it so and i'm
not mad i'm not
i'm not saying you're wrong i'm just
saying i can't do it and i i can tell
you
most of my friends would be happy to do
it for the money they were paying me
and so the next day they called and said
well listen ernie um
we really want this to work so how about
we change the name
uh and from bamboo his name is smite
and uh we still like the the voodoo
priest thing but he's a voodoo priest
who
graduated from oxford so and and
he has a british accent and if we can do
the
um i mean we don't have cebuana
and so they did no gold teeth let's get
rid of the gold teeth uh
in the earring who does that you know so
wow we're able to work it out and
normally you know you you're so angry
that you go
you call them races you see a bunch of
awful things
and now is a battle and now everybody
hates everybody
but i think the fact that um i learned
that you can just say no i don't i'm not
comfortable and
and i don't want to do it and people
will try to work with you
wow well listen uh you know i got 10
minutes because i know you got a busy
schedule here so i just want to make the
most of it so
back really quickly about winston when
those kids were saying
well where does winston go wasn't there
about a story wasn't there a part that
was edited out or something
that winston was supposed to have then
then didn't happen yeah
in the very beginning and i've been
writing we have different um
recollections because we
and everyone said i'm saying i'm sorry
man but uh i don't remember it like that
i'm not saying you're wrong we're both
old men so maybe one of our memories is
a little short here but
maybe it's mine i don't know but um in
the beginning there was a backstory
winston came in in the very beginning
you know when they
first leave the university remember they
get kicked out of university
and he comes in and um and he's an
ex-air force
colonel who was a demolitions expert and
he kind of ran the ghostbusters and
so um and then just before we
started shooting they wrote him out i
mean
basically instead of coming out on page
eight he came in on page 68.
and uh and all the backstory where i
come in and we talk about who i am and
i'm auditioning and i'm explaining what
i do
he just says um you know uh there's a
steady paycheck cannot believe anything
you say
and um and i thought that's just a funny
line
but you don't get to know who this guy
is you know you just
you know it's it's a funny bit but
unfortunately it doesn't give you a lot
to play so
you so as an actor you have to bring all
of that
with you and hopefully people will see
it
you know your mailman comes up you don't
want to you don't know everything about
him but you can see
in him who he is yes and so
i yeah i think the studio probably
uh worked overtime to try and make sure
that the ghostbusters were
always thought of as three guys
and i think it's the fans and i really
appreciate the mans who really
embraced the character um
and at one point winston was uh one of
the
best-selling dolls they had and they
were surprised
but i think that's um that's because the
fans really
love the character well speaking of fans
these are my patrons this is called [ __ ]
talking with ernie hudson this will wrap
it up these are rapid
answers unless you want to talk about it
but i know priscilla is going to be
ringing in in a minute this is uh okay
sophie m
now i know here i didn't say this sophie
did now i know you ain't afraid of no
ghost
but what are you afraid of what's what
fears
what are you afraid of ernie i'm afraid
of being afraid
when i when i find myself afraid of
something i think okay something's wrong
i don't like being free i don't either
raj you've been vocal
well we already raj we already answered
your question about winston's role and
ghostbusters
but what about ghostbusters afterlife
that's coming out next year
do you have a backstory is there
something a little more there
yep yep uh yeah so jason reitman jason i
love jason
and he um yeah winston is definitely
um a complete character i love that
jason you could have given me some small
role even one like can i get you a cup
of coffee winston
something you didn't and i'm not gonna
forget it we play hockey together
brian h did you realize how popular and
cultural uh uh cultural institution
ghostbusters would be while you were
filming it
no i don't think you know you make a
movie i feel there's gonna be
like number one at the box office but
movies come and then you move on to the
next thing
i didn't expect ghostbusters five years
10 years
15 years 20 years 25 years 30 years
people are still
um seeing me on the street and yelling
who are you gonna call
so uh yeah no i didn't uh i don't think
anybody could have predicted that
uh lisa h stay puft marshmallow man when
he defeated after crossing the streams
was it real
marshmallow they used to burst all over
your something less fun it was a
shaving cream big bats of shaving cream
they poured all over us
and then they had about a ton of it that
they had raised up on a
lift and dropped down on bill atherton
walter peck uh so it was all shaving
cream it was awful
hopefully it wasn't menthol angela f
what was it like working with brandon
lee on the crow
i love brandon i know him eight years
before he did the movie
um brandon was one of those really
gracious guys who always made everybody
on the set feel welcome
and um and uh he was he was a friend and
i i just it was shocking i still can't
believe what happened happened but
um it's really tragic that that he's no
longer here i think he would have been
very proud of the movie and i think it
showed just how truly talented he was
but miranda you guys started so many
classic tv shows taxia a team and by the
way there's a list if you want to go to
his wikipedia
or imdb jesus you you work more than
anybody i've ever met
what are the first ones that pop in your
head and any one little story that's
funny from any of those
like taxi did you meet what's his name
uh
uh christopher lloyd andy kaufman do you
work with andy kaufman you got a little
funny story about andy there
you know he was working um as a waiter
during the time we were rehearsing and
he showed up on the day but he was yeah
he was funny
um the um um uh
was it actually a taxi that um tony uh
[ __ ] tony damn yeah tony danza
uh i went in and i auditioned for uh
taxi and uh
it just wasn't happening i tried to do
everything to
and they said thank you very much i knew
i didn't get the job so i walked out of
the
office and uh tony was standing on the
paramount lot
and i walked by says hey hi he started
the conversation he said how did it go
and i said i don't think it's going to
happen
is it really said come with me so he
went back in the room
and said hey i want to read with this
guy and uh we read
and uh and i got the job what yeah the
thing
the fact that he actually we and and
i see he's a friend and i see him from
time to time at different events but
um i it was just really special and rare
that he
literally took me back into the room and
uh
and gave me another chance so you didn't
know him he just came up he was like hey
how you doing what's going on we going
there on audition how'd it go how's it
going with you
and you're like uh i sucked her
yeah and then he goes let's go read you
gonna read with me everything's gonna be
great yep
that's pretty much it always i mean i
love working with him
um what a nice girl but yeah no he yeah
uh this has been amazing first of all i
i just i i really
like you you're you're you're a great
guy and i hope you come back on the on
the show
anytime if you want to come and just
have a talk i mean i love this
i hope you had fun i'd love to it was
really funny uh redemption day
when is it coming out coming out january
8th and on demand
on january 12th stolen on demand um
last but not least can you just please
give me that ernie face that you gave
your kids every once in a while they're
just kind of like they didn't want you
to do the face
that is that see that that would scare
me that's
it you're a second away from busting my
ass right now ernie
yeah we're there and you don't want to
go bad you go past this moment
i can't promise you anything it was a
moment you jumped into it and then there
was a beat where your face relaxed for a
second and that's when i go oh yeah wow
that was that would have been and you
know it works
in this business because people get real
stupid
in film and tv and entertainment i also
can do that face when people just go a
little too far
back to hell up and and people always do
i don't i know i don't play that you're
not yelling at me
this is how we're going to do this i
love it so
you have to have a you have to have a
defense that's my defense
i love it hey this has been more than a
treat uh i'd love to talk to you again
man thanks for allowing me to be inside
of you today man i hope you had fun man
have a great time thank you stay safe
and uh healthy and
yeah sweet saying ghostbusters keep on
busting
i love that guy i uh i hope he comes
back you know what i always
hope is it sad that i always hope that
the guests like me
i'm like i hope bernie liked me i hope
when they call him a year from now and
they go mr hudson michael rosamond like
the interview who's that
michael rosenbaum you did a podcast from
no no i do know a podcast
that guy kept bringing up my past no no
no
but my children i don't want to talk to
him
um i want to give another shout out to
all the patrons and and thank you guys
remember sun spin my band
is playing just go to stage it dot com
type in sunspin
merch should be up if not today on
sunspin.com
awesome merch lunch boxes and [ __ ] you
could also go to the inside of you
online store for
mugs autographed lunch boxes from small
little pictures tons of [ __ ] on there
um and where can they go see you ryan me
yeah you got stuff on youtube all the
time i mean i'm at tias ryan on the
instas and the twits
at tias it's t-e-l-l-e-z uh
and stuff comes up on the warp zone
every now and again did you see my 2020
recap wrap i did not see that yet
should i watch that yeah you've never
heard of it ryan's amazing and he's just
he's
really funny and he's really dry and
he's got this sense of humor that when
you watch you just
you're engaging and you're funny and
you're a good guy so it's hard to
sort of you don't look like you're an
arse like his because
you know sardonic or sort of uh you know
guys
that are there's a lot of people that
can come off as [ __ ]
like uh what's his name uh paul rudd
like i like paul i've met him he's a
nice guy but he can come off like maybe
he's like
that kind of like sarcastic dick but
he's not that's just kind of who he is
he's just like
you know they have that sort of sense
but you don't you don't come off that
way i can be a sarcastic dick you
sarcastic dick yeah
i want to be let's give a shout out to
all the big ass and by the way write a
review please
if you're here still and if you still
haven't you've listened to the podcast
just go to
apple podcast write a review and
subscribe on youtube and apple
podcasts and everywhere else it really
helps the show and we're trying to you
know
grow the show i love this i've turned
this into a bit of a career and
i i'm just really passionate about it i
never thought i'd be passionate about
this so
uh whatever help you could do it's you
know it's all right here we go
this these are the patrons who make this
show very possible and thank you
westwood one who makes the show possible
and thank you to ryan my editor and
engineer
thank you to bryce my producer thank you
to everybody out there who
sent me gifts for the holidays and um uh
and all that jazz patrons nancy d
leah s that's correct stubbs
tricia f sarah v little lisa you
kiko jill e yes
my god brian
h son of a b lauren
g yes nico p robin s
jerry w emily f
robert c b
how did he do it jason w stephen j
kristen k amelia oh allison
l jess uh j oh g oh crap i don't
remember this one
j jess j lucas m raj
c joshua d emily f
s damn c j p samantha
m i i can't believe what you're doing
right now well every time i do it i have
a visual aid
right right next to me so i know oh my
god this is genius
jennifer p no n well there is uh
jennifer n
correct jackie p stacy l carly
t jennifer uh p
f s s janelle b carey
m b
kimberly f e crystal h
mike e marissa n correct
el danzu what
eldon supremo it's a new one oh that's
fun jack
s correct mira correct
beth b santiago uh
and m sarah b
g f f chad w
leanne p rauschen h
o r r rey
ray hey
s tiffany i kendrick f
ashley p jeez ashley e
shannon n d matt
w yes belinda carlisle n
narlyl kevin um
v v james r yes chris
f h anusha w
man you're almost done here uh osborne h
amy i c dave
s h samantha f spiderman
chase sheila g
[Music]
h there's another ray alyssa c tabitha
t misha um
h h it's getting to the end now it's
hard to remember tom
t natalie622 not to be confused with
natalie623
suzanne just think susan b
anthony susan b susan b suzanne yeah
henry
s kdf liliana a michelle k maru's w
marcus w marcus w hannah b
michael s talia m luke h john s
andrew a t christy s we'll do these next
week just the end
of these claire m liz j laura l
chad b rochelle e and nathan e you know
why you don't know them they're
new they're new patrons a lot of them
are new patrons and i am delighted to
say welcome to the family
patrons are are just awesome and uh
i'm excited about the band the music's
coming out we're gonna start releasing
songs in the next month
and the cd is coming out we've worked
really hard and people have been so
supportive and uh i think you're gonna
really like the music so give it a
chance i know there's a lot of music out
there but
i hope you give it a chance thank you
for allowing me to be inside of you
from my friend ryan tez and i here at
rosenbaum studio
in the middle of nowhere in the
hollywood hills uh
wave at the camera ryan thanks for
allowing me to be inside of you guys
[Music]